après l'espace les nouvelles
technologies internet c'est le nom des
nouvelles autoroutes de l'information
qui parcourt le monde avec un simple
clavier d'ordinateur vous pouvez donc
avoir accès pratiquement à toutes les
banques de données et tout savoir sur
tout ou presque
l'amérique nous précèdent bien entendu
dans ce domaine est actuellement on en
est à un nouveau un nouvel abonné toutes
les 20 secondes dans le monde patricia
charnley et si on leur explication
bienvenue dans le monde d'internet
en pénétrant dans cette banque mondiale
de données vous rejoignez les 30
millions de brancher au sens propre
keane avril jour et nuit sur ce réseau
informatique planétaire l'internet a été
créée dans les années 60 par les
militaires américains
puis les universitaires se sont
connectés à un réseau informatique
reliant des ordinateurs dans le monde
entier s'est alors développée pour y
avoir accès il suffit de disposer d'un
micro ordinateur et de souscrire
l'abonnement environ 250 francs par mois
vous pouvez alors communiqué avec la
planète
exemple avec bill clinton le président
américain reçoit tous vos messages et la
maison blanche et répond au delà de
cette messagerie universel on trouve
tout sur internet
quasiment tout ce que les hommes tu
écris ou photographiés au cours des 50
dernières années y compris un bon nombre
de reproduction de force plus anciennes
y compris l'information touristique des
informations de jeu la haye manière de
commander une pizza la filmographie de
barcamps poster
le plan du shopping à singapour
quasiment tous internet est aussi
gigantesque banque d'informations ainsi
cette petite entreprise de bobigny en
région parisienne spécialisée en
mécanique électronique a découvert dans
les ordinateurs des plus grandes
universités américaines des programmes
informatiques très utile pour son
développement
les chercheurs américains expliquant sur
le réseau leurs plus récents travaux
il faut qu'on fasse attention de ne pas
réinventer des choses qui existent parce
que c'est une perte de temps et d'argent
donc pour nous c'est vraiment un moyen
de production
cette information et ça se compte
vraiment en argent à ce niveau là
l'accès à toutes ces informations est
gratuit c'est l'un des principes de base
internet
de même l'absence de chef la plus grande
liberté règne sur le réseau certains
parlent déjà de la naissance de la
démocratie électronique internet s'est
développé de façon tellement forte que
maintenant on peut plus l'arrêter et on
peut considérer que toute population qui
est soumise à la connaissance va plutôt
aller vers la démocratie que vers le
totalitarisme
al'inverse internet a déjà ses
détracteurs
les un reproche au réseau d'être déjà
ceinture et les autres disent qu'il est
polluée par les trafiquants en tout
genre
quel que soit son évolution internet
aura révolutionné l'accès au savoir